wenn doch frau berbalk von dieser
geschichte in ihrem persönlichen umfeld
erfährt und es ist die frau die deutsche
bundeskanzlerin werden möchte warum
schreitet sie dann nicht ein warum macht
sie da nicht vollalarm und sorgten dafür
dass am ende dieser lehrer diese
lehrerin ja die quittung bekommt die sie
dafür verdient dafür müsste ich mit ihr
sprechen das weiß ich nicht kann ich
ihnen nicht sagen aber ich finde dass
sie dieses mal alles richtig gemacht hat
in der kommunikation zu diesem thema
kann ich auch gern erklären wenn sie das
hören möchte sehr gerne
also erstmal finde ich das scheint ja
auch ihre meinung zu sein ein solches
arbeitsplatz ist ein no go also das geht
nun gar nicht wenn dieses arbeitsblatt
existiert davon gehe ich sicher aus
sonst macht dieses gespräch für mich
keinen sinn
dann ist das no-go und es darf nicht
sein also ich hatte mir das zu recht
kritisiert auch was sie hier zeigen geht
ja gar nicht der buchstabe in verbindung
mit dieser zeichnung das futter ganz
klar auf das wort hinaus dass wir heute
nicht benutzen wollen weil sie hat etwas
zu recht kritisiert zum zweiten finde
ich dass sie als sie erkannt hat dass
sie dabei das wort benutzt hat des
menschen verletzt dass sie überlegt hat
wie gehe ich jetzt damit um und mit dem
zentralrat da wurden darüber gesprochen
hat und sie dann die lösung gefunden hat
das wort zum newton damit ist für alle
klar um was es geht aber es wird nicht
unnötig in die welt hinausposaunt auch
das finde ich vollkommen richtig das so
zu machen
und drittens finde ich auch absolut
richtig sich gedanken zu machen ob man
mit der eigenen sprache jemand verletzt
das hat sie getan und sie hat versucht
ein problem zu benehmen das ist offenbar
gibt auch ihre zeichnung belegt ist ohne
dabei jemanden zu verletzen
deswegen finde ich da ist wirklich
nichts kritikwürdig habe einmal da führt
die frage aber nun natürlich direkt zu
ihnen denn sie versucht man gerade wegen
dieses wortes dass das würde ich jetzt
mal unterstellen genutzt war in einer
weise die nicht verletzten solltet ihr
vielleicht unpassend war oder
unverständlich satirisch aber ich würde
jetzt mal sagen dass sie niemanden
verletzen wollen
dafür versucht man sie ja aus der partei
aus
diesen müsste dieses verfahren nicht
eigentlich mit diesem vorgang
automatisch beendet sein
und so hat annalena baerbock ja in ihrem
treats gestern abend auch etwas gesagt
dass ich teile nämlich dass es einen
großen unterschied gibt zwischen dem was
sie gemacht hat und dem was ich gemacht
habe
der unterschied ist dass es bei ihr
eindeutig darum geht ein rassistisches
problem zu benennen und abzustellen
während ich in sehr umstrittenen versuch
gemacht habe etwas ironisch auszudrücken
und das hat ganz offenbar auch viele
menschen verletzt und wäre ja der ärger
darum überhaupt nicht erklärbar also da
gibt es ein riesenunterschied auch da
teile ich ihre auffassung und was das
parteiordnungsverfahren selbst angeht da
habe ich mich ja dafür ausgesprochen
dass durchzuführen weil ich finde dass
das geklärt wir haben sollte bei uns in
der partei wie die verwendung von
begriffen zu werten ist und was der
kontext bedeutet all diese fragen die da
dranhängen
aber dieses verfahren läuft und zum
laufenden verfahren kann ich mich
natürlich nicht äußern der herr palmer
genau dazu ist es denn aus ihrer sicht
aus ihrer persönlichen sicht richtig so
ein wort zu verbieten also bekämpft man
dadurch rassismus oder macht man es
dadurch nur schlimmer
also mehr wissen nicht bewusst dass
irgendjemand meiner partei solche worte
verbieten will
sondern es geht um den appell eine
bewusste sprache zu pflegen also
menschen nicht unnötig zu verletzen
den appell teile ich die diskussion die
wir jetzt gerade für ist eine andere
nämlich ob es in bestimmten kontexten
notwendig sein kann
wörter explizit zu benutzen um etwas
überhaupt verständlich zu machen
und hier hat annalena baerbock gezeigt
dass das nicht immer notwendig ist wir
wissen alle worum es geht obwohl wir
jetzt 40 minuten lang das wort nicht
benutzt haben
und wenn es nicht notwendig ist so ein
wort zu benutzen dann finde ich absolut
richtig er ist zu vermeiden
das aber ist ganz anderes und verbot das
ist sozusagen bewusstes sprechen und
rücksichtnahme auf andere die man sonst
unnötig verletzen würde da bin ich dafür
herr palmer von der cdu
bildungsministerin aus
schleswig-holstein karin brieden kommt
die forderung dass annalena baerbock den
fall ja ein stück bei transparent und
öffentlich macht und eben uns allen klar
macht welche schule ist die betroffenen
worum genau ging es da ist das eine
forderung oder zumindest eine idee wo
sie sagen ja das finden sie sind vorher
das hätten sie auch gerne
also ich gehe davon aus wenn die bild
-zeitung solche fragen stellt die
bundespressekonferenz ansteht dass wir
davon selbst mehr darüber erfahren
werden
um was es geht ich denke auch dass wir
das alle gern verstehen wollen dass
solche dinge abgestellt werden müssen
aber wenn es von der politischen
konkurrenz kommt dann drängt sich
natürlich auch ein bisschen der verdacht
auf dass er bereits wahlkampf gemacht
und da möchte ich mich jetzt wirklich
nicht daran beteiligen